s
les paroles qu'on va lutter
contre les changements
climatiques.
C'est là qu'il va agir.
- La CAQ demandait aux Québécois
de patienter et d'attendre
au budget. C'est le temps
de déposer un plan concret.
- Beaucoup d'annonces,
d'engagements, je crois pas
tellement au père Noël.
Il faudrait qu'ils abandonnent
certaines de leurs promesses.
- On va respecter toutes
nos promesses.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Non, mais j'aime le titre :
Vos priorités, votre budget...
votre gouvernement.
C'est pas le gouvernement de la
CAQ, c'est pas le gouvernement
du Parti libéral,
c'est votre gouvernement.
- Exact.
- Le gouvernement des citoyens.
Très... très bonne idée.
- C'est un honneur.
- Vos priorités, votre budget,
voici le titre du tout premier
budget caquiste de l'histoire du
Québec, premier budget pour le
nouveau ministre des finances
Éric Girard, un budget important
il va sans dire pour le
gouvernement de François
Legault. Après les mots, voici
les chiffres aujourd'hui qui
vont tomber. Beaucoup de
promesses qui ont été faites. La
grande promesse était de
remettre de l'argent dans les
poches des Québécois. Deuxièmes
promesses, miser sur
l'éducation, remettre de
l'argent en santé également,
établir des taxes scolaires
moins élevées partout sur le
territoire québécois. Des places
pour les maternelles quatre ans,
etc. dans quelle mesure, vous
voyez les documents qui ont été
remis au journaliste et au
député dans 25 minutes. Copie de
ce budget. Nos collègues
Sébastien Bovet et Gérald
Fillion sont dans le huis clos
actuellement. Mais mes camarades
Alex Boissonneault, Michel s'est
C. Auger et René Vézina.
- Avec cette chronique de
surplus annoncé, c'est comme ça
qu'on peut l'appeler, ce budget,
il va falloir voir l'adéquation
entre le surplus et la hauteur
de ce surplus. M. Legault disait
qu'on va remplir toute notre
nos promesses. Il y en a pour 2
milliards de dollars.
Est-ce qu'il y aura des crédits
pour tout le monde? Il y a eu
tellement de groupes qui ont
senti qu'il y avait de quoi se
nourrir. On verra. Il y a
tellement d'attente. Autrement,
au budget fédéral, c'était le
contraire. Dans ce cas-ci, les
attentes sont très grandes et il
y aura certainement des gens qui
seront insatisfaits contenus de
tout ce qu'on attendait.
- Il y a un gros surplus. On
verra le montant exact de ce
surplus. On parlait jusqu'à cinq
ou 6 milliards de surplus. C'est
pour une année. Ça crée beaucoup
d'attente. Mais c'est un surplus
qui ne reviendra pas
nécessairement à toutes les
années.
- C'est pas pour toujours. Géant
devoir la transformation de M.
Girard en banquier. Normalement,
un banquier, c'est prudent. Un
politicien quand c'est assis sur
un gros montant d'argent,
d'habitude, ça ne peut pas
résister à la tentation de
dépenser. Pour la CAQ, leur
cadre financier, on parle d'une
augmentation beaucoup plus
substantielle pour les dépenses.
Si on regarde les chiffres
maintenant, on est pas sur une
pente qui permet d'avoir des
augmentations durables à ce
niveau des crédits du
gouvernement.
- Les gens se demandent :
comment se fait-il qu'on peut
donner des chiffres?
Le budget des dépenses du
gouvernement, les crédits dans
le langage familier à Québec,
ils sont donnés, dépose à
l'Assemblée nationale lendemain
du dépôt du budget. Aujourd'hui,
et l'on fait la journée même et
ce n'est pas sous le coup du
secret budgétaire parce qu'il
n'y a pas de mesures fiscales
là-dedans. C'est des mesures de
dépenses de chaque ministère. Et
vous allez nous présenter des
tableaux. Ça donne une bonne
idée de la couleur de la
journée.
- De bons indices.
C'est effectivement pas une
erreur de l'Assemblée nationale.
Il avait fait l'année dernière
aussi. Vous allez voir des
tableaux. Ça nous donne une idée
de l'augmentation des dépenses,
la stratégie des dépenses dans
ce budget des dépenses de 2019
et 2020.
On voit une bonne éducation.
Ce qui est présenté aussi, c'est
la déclinaison du plan québécois
des infrastructures.
15 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires.
Pour l'environnement, c'est une
surprise.
- C'est important, cette ligne!
- Le 1er octobre, M. Legault ne
pensait pas donner tant d'argent
à l'environnement. Ça donne 16,6
milliards sur 10 ans.
Les gens de la Capitale-
Nationale, soyez attentif.
Réseau routier, 5,3 milliards de
dollars supplémentaires sur 10
ans pour entre autres le
troisième lien entre Québec et
Lévis à l'est.
Pour ce qui est des dépenses de
programmes, augmentation de 5,8
%. C'est plus que le 4,1 % dont
il était question dans le cadre
financier.
- L'autre chez, de 2014 à 2018,
en moyenne, les dépenses de
programmes ont augmenté de 3,1
%. Et pour l'année qui commence,
ce sera de 5,8 %. Je veux
entendre René Vézina et Michel C
Auger.
C'est sur 10 ans, 16,6 milliards
pour l'environnement.
Quand même, c'est de l'argent.
- On ouvre les vannes et c'est
particulier parce que c'est
vraiment, Michel le soulignait,
c'est une grosse augmentation
des dépenses, à 5,8 %.
C'est particulier qu'on le fasse
dans la première année du
mandat. Habituellement, la
mémoire étend ce qu'elle est, on
se garde beaucoup de coussins
pour la dernière année du
mandat, pour contenter un peu
tout le monde. Comme il y a
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur la
suite des choses, j'espère qu'on
aura quand même mis des réserves
pour être en mesure de
continuer. Rien de pire que
d'habitués des gens ou des
groupes à avoir beaucoup de
manoeuvres, de marges de manoeue
et après devoir comprimer.
- Le réseau de l'éducation, 6,1
% d'augmentation. Le réseau de
l'éducation avait besoin terre
et demander de la. Maintenant il
y a de la.
- Il y en a beaucoup. Les
maternelles quatre ans. C'est
l'ensemble du réseau, les
bâtiments, les écoles qui sont
souvent vétustes. Il va falloir
investir beaucoup. Il y a
beaucoup de rattrapage à faire.
Le plan québécois des
infrastructures 2019, 2020,
c'est 115 milliards de
dollars... pour 2019 et 2029.
- En éducation, quand ont-ils
6,1 %, dans le cadre financier,
c'était moins. On crée d'autres
besoins comme les maternelles
quatre ans. Ça coûte cher. Il y
a aussi de l'infrastructure. Les
écoles, tout le monde le sait,
sont en piteux état. C'est
normal qu'il y ait ces dépenses.
En même temps, est-ce que c'est
durable? Est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir ce même genre de dépenses
les autres années qui suivront?
C'est difficile avoir d'autant
qu'on est en situation haussière
sur les marchés. Beaucoup de
gens disent qu'on s'en va vers
un ralentissement économique. Je
ne voudrais pas prononcer le mot
récession.
- Alex, on parle
d'environnement, ce nouveau
chiffre qu'on a sorti dans les
crédits budgétaires. Encore une
fois, on parle de voies
réservées, de transports en
commun. Il y a cette bataille
pour le tramway de Québec. Le
premier ministre actuellement
rencontre le maire de Québec, M.
Labeaume, parce qu'on se demande
comment on va financer ce
tramway qui est de 3,1 milliard.
On s'attendra plus argent du
fédéral.
- La rencontre est terminée. Je
vous corrige. Ça fait 20 minutes
que c'est terminé. Je viens
juste de voir M. Labeaume.
- Est-ce qu'il a un sourire?
- Non. Il ne semble pas très
content de la rencontre. Il ne
voulait pas commenter cette
rencontre à la sortie.
Il va nous parler après le
budget. Cela étend dit, il
n'était pas content quand il est
arrivé à la rencontre. Notre
collègue l'a vu rentrer. Vous
allez le voir dans quelques
secondes. Là aussi, on sentait
dans son expression corporelle
qu'il a des comptes à régler.
Même chose pour M. Legault qui a
dit un peu plus tôt
effectivement, il n'y a pas
grand-chose qu'il peut faire. M.
Legault ne veut pas toucher aux
enveloppes que propose le
gouvernement fédéral pour
financer le tramway. Le total,
3,1 milliard de dollars. Québec
est prêt à mettre 1,8 milliards.
On attendait dans le budget
fédéral 1,2 milliards pour
le tramway à Québec. Fédéral
propose 500 millions pour
l'ensemble du Québec consacré au
tramway.
- Il manque 800 millions. On va
écouter les extraits à ce sujet
un peu plus tôt avant la
rencontre. M. Labeaume a parlé.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Est-ce qu'on peut prendre
complètement ce 500 millions
puis le donner à une
municipalité? Mais si on
décidait de le faire,
si vous faites un petit calcul,
il manquerait quand même
300 millions.
Donc, le gouvernement fédéral
a pas livré la marchandise.
- Des espoirs?
- Dans quel état d'esprit...
dans quel état d'esprit
vous êtes, monsieur Labeaume?
RÉGIS LABEAUME, maire de Québec
- Je le sais pas.
Je suis ouvert.
Faut régler les problèmes.
- Mais ce matin, le premier
ministre a été clair, il a dit
qu'il avait pas de solution.
j'imagine que ça vous déçoit?
- On va voir.
FRANÇOIS-PHILIPPE CHAMPAGNE min.
féd. Infrastruc., Collectivités
- Nous, on va être au rendez-
vous, on est déjà au rendez-
vous. Évidemment, ça demandera
une participation
du gouvernement du Québec aussi,
de nos partenaires municipaux.
Mais je dirais que,
dans l'immédiat, il y a quand
même des sommes importantes.
- On sent que le gouvernement,
les ministres fédéraux
commencent à être impatientés
face aux demandes M. Legault.
- Le problème, c'est que c'est
dans des enveloppes. Après ça,
on dit : vous l'avez reçu.
Prenez le de l'enveloppe et
mettez-le dans une autre
enveloppe. C'est ce que le
gouvernement du Québec n'aime
pas. M. Legault avait bien
raison. Il a reçu 500 millions
de dollars pour les
municipalités.
Imaginez si on donne tout cet
argent à Québec.
Catherine,
on sait que le premier ministre
a fait de l'éducation
sa priorité à son arrivée
au pouvoir. Les attentes sont
donc énormes dans le milieu?
- Tout à fait. Transport en
commun, on a parlé plutôt,
Valérie Plante qui veut
absolument sa ligne rose. La
commission scolaire de Montréal
est la plus grosse Québec. On se
sent parfois mal aimé, les
commissions scolaires par le
gouvernement Legault. On craint
certaines choses. D'une part, le
manque à gagner à la suite de
cette uniformisation de la taxe
scolaire. Il y a beaucoup de
besoins. Le parc immobilier à
Montréal est très vieux, les
écoles sont vétustes. On manque
de place. Il y a des roulottes
un peu partout comme à l'école
où je me trouve dans le quartier
Rosemont. Les commissions
scolaires attendent l'argent. Le
syndicat des enseignants aussi.
Entre autres, la fédération
autonome de l'enseignement qui
dit : on a beaucoup souffert de
l'austérité libérale qu'on a
faite trop de compression.
Faudrait réinvestir près de 900
millions avec ce nouveau
gouvernement juste pour que
l'école publique puisse sortir
la tête de l'eau un peu. Il dit
qu'il faut revaloriser le métier
d'enseignant. Il manque des
enseignants. Oui, on a entendu
que c'était la priorité du
gouvernement. On souhaite que ça
soit démontré dans ce budget. Ce
sera le premier test, dit la
fédération.
SYLVAIN MALLETTE, président,
Féd. autonome de l'enseignement
- On perçoit dans le discours du
gouvernement Legault une volonté
de réparer les pots cassés
en éducation. Maintenant, c'est
par le budget qu'on voit si
les moyens seront mis en place
pour réparer les pots cassés.
Donc, ça ne peut pas uniquement
être que dans le discours,
il faut que les gestes suivent
et c'est aujourd'hui le test
qui va permettre de connaître
le degré de sincérité
du premier ministre.
- L'autre aspect, on a parlé
plus tôt, on a appris que
l'augmentation en éducation sera
de 6,1 %, ce qui est quand même
un pourcentage appréciable,
beaucoup plus élevé que durant
les dernières années. À
surveiller l'implantation des
fameuses maternelles quatre ans.
- Ce sera surveillé entre autres
par les commissions scolaires
qui vont vouloir savoir combien
on va leur donner pour implanter
ces maternels. Ça prend
davantage de ressources, de
place aussi. C'est surveillé
aussi par le milieu de la petite
enfance. La fédération des
intervenants à la petite enfance
dite avoir rencontré et fait le
tour du Québec et dire que
beaucoup de parents n'en veulent
pas. Elle veut qu'on augmente le
nombre de places dans le réseau
des CPE. Ça aussi, ça va être à
surveiller. Ces gens se disent
contre la maternelle quatre ans.
C'est une promesse qui commence
à se concrétiser par ce
gouvernement de François
Legault.
- Merci beaucoup Catherine.
Alors, une petite pause. On
revient et ce sera presque le
moment où on aura toutes les
données de ce premier budget
deux Éric Girard. À tout de
suite!
Dans une dizaine de minutes,
nous pouvons prendre la mesure
de ce premier budget deux Éric
Girard. Premier budget d'un
nouveau gouvernement. Il y a de
la fébrilité à Québec. Plus que
d'habitude.
- On sent qu'il y a un
changement de paradigme. On sait
très bien, les gens sont
conscients que les étoiles sont
alignées en faveur du
gouvernement. Les promesses
étaient grandes, les attentes
sont grandes. Il y a des
représentants de la société
civile, des municipalités, des
agriculteurs, des entrepreneurs.
Ces gens se rendent au Salon
bleu. Ils vont écouter le
ministre des finances Parlee et
présenter son budget. Et tout de
suite après, ils vont réagir. On
sait que des gens seront déçus.
Les attentes sont très grand à
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Dans quelle mesure on est au
courant de la façon dont on a
travaillé au ministère des
finances avec le premier
ministre? Des fois les premiers
ministres sont tout près
derrière le ministre des
finances et surveille. Qu'est-ce
que vous en savez?
- Ce que Éric Girard disait hier
lorsqu'il a présenté ses
espadrilles de course, il a
travaillé sept jours sur sept
dans les dernières semaines. Il
semblait fatigué. Dit qu'il est
fié de ce qu'il a fait. Il a
beaucoup consulté sur le terrain
pour voir ce que les gens ont
besoin, voire où il devrait
dépenser de l'argent. Il a des
surplus budgétaires, mais une
inconnue, est-ce qu'il va y
avoir beaucoup de dépenses
récurrentes? S'assurer que ça
coûte pas trop cher au bout de
la ligne dans trois ans. Pour
monsieur Girard, il a travaillé
très fort disait il y a.
- René Vézina, faire le saut
entre banquiers et ministre des
finances, ça a dû demander une
adaptation.
- Vous gérez pour l'entreprise
qui doit dégager des profits
pour ses actionnaires et vous
arrivez dans l'espace public où
il faut combler des besoins en
essayant de contempler un peu
tout le monde, l'ensemble des
parties prenantes, c'est un show
impressionnant. Il a l'air à
l'aise. On verra. C'est pas un
ministre... on n'a pas vu de
coche mal taillée. Quand on
pensait aux dépenses
récurrentes, les demandes des
municipalités, on avait promis
de leur redonner 1,0 deux TVQ.
C'est près d'un milliard de
dollars par année. Est-ce qu'on
pourra s'affranchir de l'impôt
foncier comme on le demande
depuis des décennies? Est-ce
qu'on est en mesure... c'est le
genre d'engagement... à part les
autres, est-ce qu'on sera
capable d'aller vraiment les
contenter?
- Michel C Auger, il y aura
baisse de la taxe municipale.
C'est l'attaque scolaire. Il y
aura ce grand ménage qui avait
été promis. Il y aura de
l'argent qui est redonné aux
Québécois, dans la poche
québécois. Michel, c'est un
incontournable. C'est
télégraphié.
- Ce ne sera pas nécessairement
des baisses d'impôts. Il y a
l'attaque scolaire, des
allocations familiales, retour à
la tarification unique dans les
garderies. Pour le gouvernement,
c'est de l'argent dans les
poches des gens. Mais déplaise
comme tel... mais déplaise impôt
sur le revenu, c'est pas dans
les cartons.
- Lorsqu'il parlait des écarts
de rendement de Hydro-Québec,
c'est son argument de redonner
de l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables.
Comme par exemple huit dollars
par jour pour les garderies.
- René Vézina, souligné nous le
côté inhabituel de l'exercice
aujourd'hui dans la mesure où
les surplus, ça fait cinq ans
qu'on couvre des budgets à
Québec où il n'y a pas beaucoup
de surplus. C'est plutôt dans
l'austérité et on a rattrapé et
on a tenté de réduire les
dépenses plus possibles. Pour
leur prendre le mot à la mode,
on est dans un autre paradigme.
- Avec la création d'emplois au
Québec avec des entreprises qui
font de meilleures affaires, il
était clair qu'on allait
recevoir de meilleures rentrées,
qu'on allait avoir de meilleures
rentrées fiscales. Mais à ce
point là, ce serait étonnant. Il
faudra voir vraiment jusqu'où on
est allé. Il y a en effet des
mesures de la rigueur qu'on
avait voulu imposer plus tôt. On
a peut-être faisait un peu trop
là-dessus. Mais il y a une
résultante.
- On récolte les fruits de M.
Leitao.
- Ça arrive pas du ciel. Est-ce
qu'on est capable de prévoir que
cet appel machine roulera,
baignera dans l'huile pour les
années à venir? C'est une
question qu'on devra se poser.
Commence avec une augmentation
de dépenses aussi imposantes
d'entrée de jeu, c'est quand
même prendre un méchant pari.
- Michel C Auger, grâce au dépôt
du budget des crédits, nous
savons que les dépenses des
programmes vont augmenter de 5,8
%, moyenne des année libérale,
c'était 3,2. Il y a un banquier
significatif.
- Il y a aussi la bonne
performance de l'économie
québécoise et canadienne. Au
budget fédéral, il y avait
plusieurs milliards de plus dans
les coffres du gouvernement à
cause des rentrées
supplémentaires. Le gouvernement
s'en est servi pour faire des
bonbons électoraux. Le Québec
fait parti de ce mouvement.
L'économie va bien, les rentrées
d'argent du gouvernement sont
bonnes. C'est peut-être l'année
où on peut faire un effort
supplémentaire par exemple pour
le parc immobilier des écoles.
Encore une fois, c'est pas
durable nécessairement comme
croissance. Il faudra voir dans
les prochaines années ce qui va
se passer. Mais c'est un fait,
actuellement, c'est une
situation très intéressante pour
tous les gouvernements. M.
Morneau s'en est servi de façon
très directe et électorale.
- Gérald Fillion, vous étiez
dans ce huis clos. Vous venez
d'arriver. Le secret budgétaire
n'est pas encore levé parce que
le ministre n'a pas déposé, si
je comprends bien, encore, on
peut quand même vous dire
bonjour. On peut parler de la
situation.
- Je peux vous montrer le budget
parce que le ministre l'a montré
un peu plus tôt. Un budget
de taille moyenne par rapport à
ce qu'on a vu au cours des
dernières années. Je peux pas
vous dire ce qu'il y a dedans.
Mais je peux être d'accord avec
mes collègues qui disent que
l'économie va bien, qu'il y a
des rentrées de revenus qui sont
au rendez-vous. Bien sûr, ça a
permis au ministre Girard de
présenter un premier budget dans
des conditions très, très
favorable.
- Il a une marge de manoeuvre
qu'on n'avait pas connu au
Québec depuis cinq ou six ans et
même plus que ça.
- Je me rappelle pas d'avoir vu
une marge de manoeuvre comme
celle-là. Le travail des
libéraux au cours des dernières
années a permis de dégager cette
marge de manoeuvre, la croissane
économique également, l'institut
du Québec disait il y a quelques
semaines : on s'en va vers des
surplus de quatre jusqu'à 7
milliards avant le fonds des
générations pour l'exercice 2018
2019. C'est dans ce contexte que
le ministre Girard a prie
possession des finances
publiques et a pu travailler à
mettre en place le début des
promesses de la CAQ, le dédet fr
l'ensemble du mandat.
- On a présenté quelques données
que l'on peut présenter, la
croissance des dépenses, parce
qu'on a déposé ce matin les
crédits budgétaires. Ne sont pas
frappés du huis clos parce qu'il
n'y a pas de mesures fiscales
dedans. On va les remontrer aux
gens, des dépenses de programmes
qui décollent en santé, de façon
générale, 5,8 % d'augmentation
des dépenses de programme pour
l'année qui commence par rapport
aux quatre et cinq dernières
années qui est à 3,1 %. Il y a
un baume dans les dépenses de
programmes.
6,1 % d'augmentation dans
l'éducation. Également les
nouvelles classes de maternelle
quatre ans qu'on veut financer.
6 % d'augmentation pour la santé
et les services sociaux.
Environnement, et ça, c'est plus
que ce qu'on croyait, ce que
eux-mêmes croyaient mettre,
presque 17 milliards sur 10 ans.
Le réseau routier, on va y
mettre 5,3 milliards
supplémentaires. Ça comprend le
début de ce troisième lien entre
Québec et Lévis.
C'est assez rare qu'on donne la
même journée. Souvent, c'est le
lendemain ou le surlendemain.
- Le budget des dépenses, c'est
à tous les jours... c'est à tous
les budgets, c'est le même jour
que le budget. La seule fois où
c'était pas le même jour, c'est
le gouvernement de Pauline
Marois, 20 février 2014 qui
n'avait même pas déposé de
dépenses avant de déclencher
l'élection.
- C'est même arrivé avant.
Mais vous étiez plus jeune.
Parce qu'il y a des contraintes
parlementaires qui font que des
fonds est obligé de déposer les
crédits à une certaine date que
le budget n'est pas prêt. Voilà,
on a pu en parler.
- Le budget est rendu
extrêmement complexe. Il y a des
entités consolidées, des entités
non consolidées, surplus avant
le fonds des générations, après,
il y a beaucoup de poste
budgétaire ce qui fait que les
chiffres que vous venez de
montrer son dans le budget des
dépenses. Lorsqu'on regarde le
budget d'opération, les missions
changent un peu parce qu'on
donne des croissances de
dépenses en fonction des
missions. Alors j'espère qu'on
ne va pas vous ensevelir de
chiffre et vous mélangez. Ce
nom, vous serez là pour tout
démêler.
Les gens sont entrés.
- Oui, il se déplace
tranquillement vers le salon
bleu. Ici, on sent la fébrilité.
Les gens veulent savoir ce qu'il
va se passer parce qu'on parle
tellement des surplus
budgétaires que les gens se
disent : si ce n'est pas
maintenant que je reçois ce que
je devis recevoir, quand vais-
je recevoir. Gabriel Nadeau-
Dubois disait : on a la pire
crise environnementale et on a
le plus gros surplus alors on
devrait avoir les dépenses.
- Quelqu'un qui va regarder ça
avec des yeux particuliers,
c'est Carlos Leitao qui a
présenté les cinq derniers
budgets et il doit se sentir un
peu bizarre aujourd'hui.
- Je pense qu'il aimerait un
petit mot dans le discours de
Monsieur Girard pour dire : ce
gros surplus, on le doit un peu
à Monsieur Leitao. Je ne pense
pas que ça va arriver mais c'est
clair qu'aujourd'hui, quand il
va réagir, il va faire remarquer
lourdement que si le
gouvernement a sa marge de
manoeuvre, c'est grâce à lui. Il
y avait du pour et du contre
mais c'est de là que ça vient.
Un petit mot sur
l'environnement. 16 milliards,
ça paraît beaucoup mais sur 10
ans, ça fait 1,6 milliards par
année. Ce n'est pas énorme. Et
d'autre part, Alex disait, le
maire de Québec un petit peu
malheureux aujourd'hui. Ce n'est
peut-être pas juste à cause du
fait qu'il ne semble pas y avoir
d'argent pour le tramway, mais
on met pas mal de sous pour le
troisième lien, un projet auquel
il ne tient pas.
- C'est d'ailleurs ce que dit le
parti libéral. Chez les
libéraux, on dit... ses revenus
pendant la période des
questions. On disait : est-ce
que Monsieur Legault, vous
voulez préserver les autres
enveloppes pour pouvoir payer le
troisième lien? Est-ce que cet
esprit qu'on va se passer par
exemple du tramway? Pour les
libéraux, il y a peut-être des
questions à se poser.
- Et dans le budget des
infrastructures, de toute façon,
c'est à l'intérieur de ce
budget, on emprunte de l'argent
pour investir dans les
infrastructures. Je voulais
ajouter un petit mot Patrice :
le ministre Girard a salué le
travail de son prédécesseur
aujourd'hui. Il a dit : je
retrouve des finances publiques
en ordre, en bonne santé et
c'est ce qui me permet d'arriver
et de présenter ce budget en
tentant de bonifier la situation
des finances publiques au
Québec. C'est assez rare que le
ministre des Finances parlant
bien d'un autre ministre d'un
autre parti. C'est la réalité.
On nage dans les surplus alors
le ministre Girard l'a bien
reconnu.
- Monsieur Girard qui a été
candidat pour le parti
conservateur fédéral, il n'est
pas le plus partisan. C'est
quelqu'un... lors de sa première
conférence de presse, pendant
qu'on voit des images en direct
avec le président qui va appeler
le ministre Girard...
- Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés, bonjour. Sans plus
tarder, Monsieur le leader du
gouvernement.
- Je vous demanderai de
reconnaître le ministre des
Finances de Québec s'il vous
plaît.
- Monsieur le ministre des
Finances.
(Applaudissements)
juste avant, permettez-moi de
vous rappeler une règle claire :
il n'y a pas d'applaudissements
dans les tribunes s'il vous
plaît. Monsieur le ministre des
Finances prononcera maintenant
le discours sur le budget.
Monsieur le ministre des
Finances, je vous cède la
parole.
- Monsieur le président, je suis
fier de présenter le premier
budget d'un gouvernement de la
CAQ, un budget grâce auquel nous
investissons maintenant pour
maîtriser notre avenir.
(Applaudissements)
(brouhaha de voix)
(rires)
Monsieur le président, vous me
permettrez de m'adresser d'abord
à mon premier ministre. Monsieur
le Premier ministre, je vous
remercie de m'avoir confié
l'important dossier des finances
dans le gouvernement que vous
dirigez. Grâce à cette
confiance, j'ai l'honneur de
servir les Québécois dans des
fonctions stratégiques au sein
de l'équipe gouvernementale.
Vous m'avez confié en même temps
une lourde responsabilité, une
responsabilité que je partage
avec l'incroyable équipe du
ministère des finances et mon
cabinet. Cette responsabilité,
je l'ai accepté avec la volonté
de mettre mes compétences et mes
efforts au service de tous les
Québécois. Nous gouvernement
pour tous et sous votre
direction, nous sommes avant
tout guidé par l'intérêt
supérieur du Québec.
En octobre dernier, nous avons
trouvé des finances publiques en
bon état. C'est finances
publiques, nous allons continuer
de les améliorer. Avec votre
appui, Monsieur le Premier
ministre, j'ai la ferme
intention de faire en sorte que
notre situation économique et
financière progresse, que le
Québec réalise ses ambitions et
que tous les Québécois en
profitent. Je souhaite
maintenant m'adresser à
l'ensemble des Québécois pour
leur dire : le budget que nous
présentons aujourd'hui, c'est
votre budget. Au cours des
derniers mois, mes collègues et
moi avons écouté la population.
Tout au long de ce processus,
nous avons été guidés par un
principe fondamental. Cet argent
que nous avons le privilège et
la responsabilité de gérer,
c'est celui des Québécois. Les
finances publiques que nous
administrant, ce ne sont pas les
finances des ministères que je
dirige ni celle des autres
ministères. Ce ne sont pas les
finances de nombreux groupes
d'intérêts concernés par les
décisions gouvernementales. Il
s'agit d'une évidence que l'on a
trop tendance à oublier que je
veux souligner : les finances
publiques dont fait état le
budget que nous présentons
aujourd'hui, ce sont les
finances publiques de tous les
Québécois. Ce sont les finances
publiques de nos familles, de
nos enfants comme de nos aînés.
Ce sont les finances publiques
des Québécois, des grandes
villes comme des villages, de la
métropole et de la capitale
nationale comme des régions. Ce
sont les finances publiques de
nos entrepreneurs et de nos
travailleurs. Ce sont les
finances publiques transmises
par nos prédécesseurs et dont
nous sommes fiduciaires pour les
prochaines générations. Jeudi
également à tous les Québécois :
votre budget a été défini à
partir de vos priorités, celle-
là même annoncée par le premier
ministre dans son discours
d'ouverture. Votre budget répond
prioritairement à vos budgets en
éducation, en santé et en
économie. Il améliore votre
pouvoir d'achat en réduisant le
fardeau fiscal. Avec ce budget,
nous répondons aux
préoccupations immédiates des
Québécois et nous préparons
l'avenir. Nous retournons plus
d'argent dans les portefeuilles
des Québécois. Nous donnons la
priorité à la réussite de nos
enfants. Nous consacrons tous
les efforts pour que les aînés
soient traités de façon
exemplaire et que les Québécois
bénéficient d'un accès rapide
aux soins de santé. Nous
agissons sur les investissements
et l'offre de travail.
- Voilà Monsieur Girard qui
poursuit la lecture de son
discours du budget. Allons-y
avec les faits saillants avec ce
budget d'Éric Girard.
- Exactement. C'est un budget
à l'équilibre budgétaire, au
déficit zéro pour le budget 2019
et 2020 sur des revenus de 115
milliards de dollars et des
dépenses de 113 milliards de
dollars au fonds des générations
et on injecte 2,5 milliards donc
après le versement, on est au
déficit zéro. Je vous ai mis
l'année 2018 et 2019 pour vous
montrer qu'on avait un surplus
de 2,5 milliards et qu'avant le
fonds des générations on était à
5,6 milliards. Pour faire le
point sur ces chiffres. C'est le
premier tableau que je vous
présente. Les faits saillants
maintenant, il y en a quatre :
pas de baisse d'impôts ni de
baisse de TVQ. Il y a des
allégements fiscaux mais pas de
baisse d'impôts. En santé, plus
d'argent pour les soins à
domicile et plus d'argent
également pour embaucher
davantage de personnel soignant.
Ça, c'est pour le secteur de la
santé qui est un des segments
les plus importants du budget du
Québec qui est le plus important
avec l'éducation également où on
va injecter davantage d'argent
dans les services spécialisés,
les classes spécialisées.
Maternels quatre ans : premier
engagement pour 250 places en
septembre 2019. C'est confirmé
mais on ne veut pas aller plus
loin sur l'engagement jusqu'à
5000 maternels. On dit que ça va
dépendre de la demande et du
succès.
60 ans, nouveau crédit d'impôt
qui en remplace un autre qui
s'appelle le crédit d'impôt pour
la prolongation de carrière pour
permettre aux gens de rester au
travail et d'avoir un gain
financier, un avantage financier
à rester au travail à 60 ans,
jusqu'à 65 et peut-être même
plus.
- Développons un peu sur
l'éducation et la santé.
Les deux secteurs les plus
importants.
- Une croissance des dépenses
assez fortes en éducation et en
santé pour 2019 et 2020 de plus
de 5 % mais en 2020 et 2021, ça
va baisser vers 3,7 % et 4,1 %
pour la santé. Regardez les
autres ministères. 4,5 % des
budget mais ça va tomber à 2 %
en 2020 et 2021. Un coup
d'accélérateur pour cette année
comme on l'avait fait dans le
dernier budget Leitao, mais un
coup de frein pour les années
suivantes. On veut jouer
davantage sur la prudence et on
nous dit qu'on dépasse les coûts
de système et même en 2020 et
2021, il dit qu'il dépasse les
coûts de système. En santé,
cette 280 millions de dollars de
plus qui sont injectés dans les
soins à domicile. La CAQ avait
parlé de 200 millions. On est à
280 millions. Les besoins sont
là et criant. Ils seront de plus
en plus importants et on ajoute
aussi du personnel soignant,
investissement supplémentaire de
200 millions de dollars pour
ajouter du personnel soignant.
En éducation, les services
spécialisés, le soutien aux
élèves, les classes spécialisées
également, les milieux en
difficulté : 92 millions de
dollars supplémentaires. Les
maternels quatre ans, 36
millions pour ce budget. 250
nouvelles classes en septembre
2019. Toujours en lien avec
l'éducation, l'enfance, la
contribution additionnelle pour
la garde d'enfants. Le tarif
unique, on confirme les
chiffres. Les gens auront droit
au tarif unique en garderie si
votre revenu familial est
inférieur à 78 320 $ cette
année. Après ça, 108 532 $
et puis pour 140 000 et en 2022,
ce sera le tarif unique pour
tous. La taxe scolaire, la
réduction commence le 1er
juillet 2019. Elle sera
uniformisée en 2021. Coût annuel
prévu de 800 millions de
dollars.
- Ça, c'est exactement ce qu'on
avait promis.
- Exactement. On est vraiment
lié sur les promesses
électorales, les annonces
jusqu'à maintenant. Ça a été
presque la première annonce du
gouvernement Legault qui avait
déjà déployé un peu cette mesure
sur l'uniformisation de la taxe
scolaire dans l'énoncé
économique.
- Vous nous parlez de mesures
pour garder les gens de 60 ans
et plus au travail...
- c'est assez fondamental parce
que dans le budget, on voit
clairement que le bassin de
travailleurs va baisser au
Québec pendant qu'il va monter
en Ontario. Donc, il faut
trouver des solutions pour avoir
des travailleurs et même que ça
ralentit l'économie. Commence
déjà à le constater. Ce crédit
d'impôt pour la prolongation de
carrière sera admissible à
partir de 60 ans. Ce moment, il
y a une mesure admissible à
partir de 61 ans donc on la
devança 60 ans et pour une
personne qui gagne par exemple
autour de 15 000 $ où il ne fait
pas d'impôts, on va ajouter 10
000 $. Donc sur les premiers 25
000 $ pas d'impôts à payer. Ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à 1500 $ de
réduction d'impôt, donc on vient
vraiment bonifier de façon
importante ce crédit d'impôt
pour encourager les gens à
rester en quelque sorte sur le
marché du travail. Autre mesure,
on a parlé d'environnement.
Le programme Roulez vert
demeure. Il est prolongé
jusqu'aux 31 mars 2021.
Ça va permettre l'achat de 66
000 véhicules électriques de
plus, l'ajout de 20 000 bornes
de recharge électrique, après
2021, la subvention de 2000 $
accessible sur nos taux de 75
000 va passer à 60 000. On va
modifier le programme Roulez
vert, mais il existe toujours.
- Infrastructures, transports
etc.
- Infrastructures, on ajoute de
15 milliards de dollars dans le
programme d'infrastructures 2019
jusqu'à 2029. En fait pas sa à
115 milliards de dollars pour
construire de nouvelles écoles,
les nouvelles classes de
maternelle quatre, les maisons
d'année, l'agrandissement de
l'hôpital de la Malbaie et
Pierre le gardeur, le troisième
lien entre Québec et Lévis, le
tramway de Québec, on ajoute à
l'étude le prolongement de la
ligne jaune à Montréal avec un
transport collectif à
déterminer, pour l'est de
Montréal également, pour le
boulevard Taschereau et la
réfection du tunnel Ville-Marie
et Viger.
Deux sommes très importantes
pour les entreprises : 1
milliard de dollars pour former
une équipe d'intelligences et
d'expertise pour mieux
protégeait les sièges sociaux.
En parle particulièrement de
SNC-Lavalin.
On ajoute 1 milliard à la
capitalisation d'investissement
Québec. On veut attirer des
investissement Québec de
l'étranger. À investissement
Québec, on va définir la réforme
au mois d'avril. Et ensuite, la
mesure fondamentale :
l'intégration des immigrants :
148 millions de dollars de plus
parce qu'on veut développer un
parcours d'accompagnement et
améliorer la francisation des
immigrants. Ça aussi, ça fait
parti des solutions pour
augmenter le bassin de main-
d'oeuvre au Québec.
- C'était la fameuse formule :
en accueillir moins mais mieux.
- Avec plus d'argent donc. C'est
ce que le budget nous dit. On un
accueil moins, mais mieux. La
dette brute et à 200 milliards
de dollars. Ces 46,1 % du PIB.
En 2020, ce sera 45 % du PIB. Je
vous rappelle qu'on prévoyait
2026 pour le 45 % donc la dette
baisse beaucoup plus rapidement
compte tenu des années passées
et le fonds des générations etc.
- Merci. Gérald,
j'ai une petite question. Le
surplus de 5,6 en fin d'année
2018 avant le versement au fond
des générations, qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait avec.
- Le fonds des générations va
chercher une partie du 5,6
milliards, donc il reste 2,5
milliards en surplus et c'est de
l'argent qu'on est de façon
comptable dans ce qu'on appelle
la réserve de stabilisation.
C'est une somme qui peut servir
à équilibrer le budget en
fonction de la loi sur
l'équilibre budgétaire. C'est
rendu 10 milliards, cette
réserve de stabilisation. Je
vous le dis, on nage dans les
milliards de dollars. Quand on
regarde le surplus de la
dernière année, le gouvernement
a vraiment les coudées franches
pour aller de l'avant et
augmenter les dépenses comme il
a décidé de le faire
aujourd'hui.
- Il y a un coût pour 2019 2020.
On ouvre les vannes.
- On n'y va avec prudence en
même temps. Le ministre et je
vous le ferai entendre, ministre
Girard nous a dit : on veut
baisser les impôts d'ici la fin
du mandat. On pense déjà à
celui-là semble-t-il.
- Bonjour Sébastien.
C'est toujours important, le
premier budget. Ça donne le
temps. On l'a beaucoup souligné
depuis le début de cette
émission, ils sont arrivés et
ils ont vu que la situation
financière était enviable. Il y
avait des marges de manoeuvre.
Quel est l'empreinte de la CAQ
là-dessus.
- On la cherche un peu. On a
l'impression que ministre
libéral des finances aurait pu
présenter à peu près le même
budget avec les mêmes marges de
manoeuvre. On réinvestit dans ls
missions fondamentales de l'État
: la santé et l'éducation. Il y
a même quelqu'un qui a prononcé
les mots : budget centre-gauche
pour qualifier le budget de
Monsieur Girard. Alors on
s'entend, on voulait pas
nécessairement avoir un feu
d'artifice dans les tons de
bleue poudre de la CAQ, mais on
aurait pu penser qu'il y aurait
eu un changement d'approche dans
ce premier budget parce que le
premier budget de gouvernement
permet de jeter les bases d'une
vision, une nouvelle vision
gouvernementale et la CAQ nous a
tellement vendu le vent de
changement qu'on cherche un peu
ce changement. On a l'impression
qu'on n'est plus dans la
continuité et quand on demande à
Monsieur Girard le ministre des
Finances en quoi son budget se
différencie de budget libéral,
voici sa réponse :
- c'est que notre budget réalise
les engagements de la CAQ en
campagne électorale. Nous sommes
déterminés à réaliser nos
engagements. Ce qui est dans le
budget, c'est ce que nous avons
promis aux Québécois. C'est ce
que le premier ministre s'est
engagé à faire alors nous
remettons de l'argent dans le
portefeuille des Québécois,
nous mettant l'emphase sur
l'éducation, les aînés se sont
imposés.
- L'année...
- les aînées,
c'est les soins à domicile.
Autre chose que Marguerite Blais
est allé chercher...
- oui, elle est allée chercher
plus de personnel soignant
pendant l'impression que c'est
un peu le budget de Marguerite
Blais. Les aînés, on ne les
avait pas vu venir comme une
priorité mais Monsieur Girard a
dit qu'il a visité le CHSLD et
il a été frappé par le rôle des
proches aidants. Il y a une
préoccupation pour les aînés,
et d'ailleurs, la fédération des
aînés du Québec disait que
c'était un peu Noël au mois de
mars parce qu'il ne s'attendait
pas à ça. Les partis
d'opposition relèvent ça et
disent que c'est une bonne chose
de s'occuper des aînés,
mais les libéraux disent :
faites attention parce qu'il y a
de l'argent à dépenser cette
année mais dans les années qui
vont venir, il va y avoir un
ralentissement de l'économie.
Les deux autres partis
d'opposition : Québec solidaire
le Parti québécois mettent
l'accent sur l'environnement.
Oui, il y a des mesures
environnementales mais ça va pas
assez loin, la CAQ n'a pas assez
de conscience environnementale.
Voici les réactions.
- L'année du budget,
c'est un peu la dernière année,
la dernière année de marge de
manoeuvre. Profitez en bien pare
que pour les années suivantes,
ça ne va pas être ça du tout.
- Il n'y a pas un plan de lutte
aux changements climatiques.
C'est une opération de
marketing. D'ailleurs, dans les
documents que l'on vous a remis,
on a fait un petit peu de green
washing avec des vos petits
logos un petit peu comme sur les
boîtes de céréales : contient
plus de fibres. Contient des
mesures vertes. Il y en a pas
vraiment.
- Dans le budget de la CAQ, on
dispose d'immenses surplus mais
ils font les mauvais choix. La
CAQ fonce tête baissée dans les
maternelles milliards mais
réduits les budgets de
construction des CPE. La CAQ
dépenses milliards pour les
maisons d'année mais ne peut pas
rénover tous les CHSLD.
- Vous dîtes, c'est intéressant,
vous avez l'impression que ça
aurait pu être le budget Leitao.
Il n'y a pas de rupture.
- C'est dans la continuité. On
réinvestit dans les missions
essentielles de l'État : en
éducation et en santé.
Les augmentations sont assez
fortes. Autour de cinq, à 5,5 %
d'augmentation. En économie, on
réinvestit. On a comme
préoccupation la pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre et il y a des
mesures intéressantes, mais on
nous avait tellement vendu de
changement dans l'approche de la
CAQ que peut-être qu'on
s'attendait plus au changement
d'approche. On a plus
l'impression qu'on est dans la
continuité d'un budget qui jouit
des normes surplus budgétaires
et pour lequel le ministre des
Finances avaient les moyens de
ses ambitions.
- René Vézina, Michel C,
Bonjour.
- Oui, bonjour. Quand on dit
qu'on nage dans l'argent, si
vous avez la réserve de
stabilisation et le fonds des
générations, et en passant on
continue à mettre de l'argent
dans le fond des générations. Il
y a environ 15 milliards de
dollars là-dedans et ça pourrait
être appliqué à la dette. C'est
intéressant qu'on puisse y
arriver. Il y a peut-être un
élément sur lequel je vais
revenir : le gouvernement disait
: on va remplir tous nos
engagements. Il y en a un qui
n'est pas rempli, c'est le fait
de redonner aux municipalités un
point de pourcentage de la TVQ
qui aurait permis d'alléger la
dépendance à l'impôt foncier et
permettre aux municipalités de
réduire eux-mêmes leur taux de
taxation foncière. Ça n'y est
pas. C'est étonnant. On dit
qu'il y aura un nouveau pacte
fiscal qui va être discuté avec
le ministre des Finances.
- Il y aura des négociations à
l'automne prochain. Ça fait
longtemps qu'il y a des
négociations. L'autre élément
que je retiens c'est que vous
savez, dans les budget souvent
il y a des annonces mais ça
s'échelonne sur cinq à 15 ans.
Dans ce cas-ci, il y a déjà des
actions tout de suite. Oui, la
taxe famille sera graduelle mais
ça commence sans tarder et c'est
un changement de temps par
rapport à ce qu'on entend
souvent.
- Appréciation et analyse
générale avant de passer à
d'autres mesures avec Gérald.
- Je voulais revenir sur les
municipalités parce que c'était
quelque chose que tous les
partis politiques sont allés
dire au maire.
1 % de la TVQ, ça s'en va chez
vous, c'est réglé les effets
mais on dit : on va négocier ça
un peu plus tard et s'il y a des
perdants là-dedans, ce sont les
municipalités parce que les
sommes, les investissements
considérables sont dans les
missions traditionnelles de
l'État c'est-à-dire la santé
l'éducation, les aînés,
mais par exemple pour le
transport et des choses comme
ça, les investissements sont là,
il y en a, mais c'est moins
important et il y a moins
d'augmentation de ses budget. Je
pense qu'on s'attendait entre
autres à Montréal où il y a un
problème de congestion majeure,
on s'attendait à de l'aide.
- Très bien. Gérald, rapidement.
Avant de parler d'autres
mesures, les années, je pense
que Sébastien nous lisait bien,
les aînés sont les grands
gagnants et dans les CHSLD et
les soins à domicile. C'est
important.
- Plus de lit, de personnel
soignant, de soutien à domicile.
Effectivement c'est important et
pour les aînés qui travaillent
toujours ou en tout cas, peut-
être que je commets un crime en
parlant des aînés à partir de 60
ans mais à partir de 60 ans...
- Un autre mot qu'on ne peut
plus utiliser. Vous pouvez
m'appeler un aîné.
- Je ne pensais pas à vous. Mais
effectivement le crédit d'impôt
est là pour permettre un
allégement fiscal pour que les
personnes de plus de 60 ans ou à
partir de 60 et envies de
continuer à travailler.
- Ça, c'est intéressant et il y
a quelque chose de nouveau. En
éducation, vous l'avez dit,
cette année, on n'en met pas mal
plus. Il y a bien sûr les
maternelles quatre ans qu'on
doit financer. Il y a aussi du
personnel de plus que l'on
souhaite dans les
établissements.
- Et du service spécialisé, de
soutien aux élèves, du travail
des psychologues également et il
y a beaucoup de travail là-
dessus. On aurait souhaité,
opposition en parler qu'il y ait
de l'argent pour les enfants
handicapés parce qu'il en avait
parlé. Ça va tarder un peu, ce
déploiement mais on dit quand
même le soutien aux élèves,
réduire le nombre d'élèves par
classe et par enseignant. C'est
dans le budget sur l'éducation.
Il y a des gens qui nous
disaient qu'on investit beaucoup
dans le béton en retour, mais en
même temps, beaucoup d'écoles
ont besoin de rénovations qui
sont importantes.
- Très bien. On l'a beaucoup dit
depuis le début donc un surplus
qui était énorme en fin d'année
au 31 mars qu'on a mis au fond
des générations, on a gardé 2,5
milliards pour la dette ce qui
fait qu'on prévoit l'an
prochain...
- 2,5 milliards avant le fonds
des générations, on le met
dedans, on est à zéro pour le
solde. Il faut comprendre qu'on
a dépensé beaucoup d'argent
durant le mois de mars 2019. Il
y a 1,6 milliards dont 250
millions annoncés pour les taxis
et on met ça dans le budget
2019.
Il y a une liste d'une trentaine
deux mesures qui ont été
pelletées dans l'exercice 2018
et 2019, dépensé au mois de mars
2019 pour faire fondre ce
surplus budgétaire. Et donc,
d'entamer la nouvelle année sur
de nouvelles bases pour les
revenus et les dépenses. On
l'avait à plusieurs reprises,
c'est pas vrai qu'on a des
surplus à plus finir.
Il n'y a pas gouvernement au
Canada qui dégage des revenus
dans ses dépenses.
- Le taux de dette est plus
élevé que le gouvernement
fédéral.
- Dans toutes les provinces, le
Québec est le troisième plus
élevé au Canada. 46 %, la dette
brute. La dette nette, c'est 45
% du PIB. C'est de faire baisser
cette dette. Le fonds des
générations asservies à ça. on a
fait un remboursement de 10
milliards de dollars à partir du
fonds des générations. La dette
baise. Le niveau d'intérêt,
service de la dette baise
également. Il est encore à 9
milliards. Mais il est moins
élevé que ce qu'il était il y a
cinq ans.
- Gérald, ouvrons une parenthèse
sur le fond des générations.
C'était sous Jean Charest.
Expliquez-nous la logique.
Plutôt que de payer toute ta
dette, mais ça dans un fonds.
C'est la caisse qui fait
fructifier ça. On se dit que ça
va et plus payant et on paiera
un jour la dette.
- Vous l'avez bien expliqué. Ça
existe depuis 2006.
Redevance sur l'eau d'Hydro-
Québec, ça va là-dedans. Il y a
différents fonds qui sont prient
chaque année et plutôt que
d'utiliser ces fonds pour
investir ailleurs, parce que
c'est quand même beaucoup
d'argent, c'est des milliards de
dollars, on le met dans le fond
des générations. Ces données
l'obligation légale de mettre ça
dans le fond des générations. Ça
fait baisser la tête sur papier.
On peut rembourser une partie de
la dette. Ça fait baisser la
dette sur papier et ça permet au
gouvernement de faire fructifier
cet argent.
C'est la caisse de dépôt qui
gère ça.
- il y a un gain.
- C'est pour ça que le
gouvernement a été critiqué de
rembourser 10 milliards. Parce
que le gain en intérêts sur le
remboursement de la dette en
prenant de l'argent dans le fond
des générations est plus faible
que le rendement qu'on a fait y
compris en 2018 on a fait 4,5 %
de rendement. On fait des gains
plus importants en investissant
que le gain qu'on fait en
intérêts en prenant humiliant
pour rembourser la dette.
- Sébastien, le milieu
économique réagit comment?
- Très bien. Il y en a même qui
donne une note de un à Éric
Girard pour son premier examen
budgétaire. Il y avait pénurie
de main-d'oeuvre. En disant que
les travailleurs d'expérience,
les gens de 65 ans et plus,
pourront avoir un crédit d'impôt
pour revenir sur le marché du
travail. Meilleure intégration
des immigrants. Des dizaines de
millions de dollars consacrés à
ça. en région, il y a un cri du
coeur pour dire : amenez-nous de
la main-d'oeuvre et on compte
notamment sur l'immigration pour
les signaux qui sont envoyés
sont de façon générale très bon.
- C'est un budget qui est très
robuste, qui reflète la solidité
du Québec et le contrôle des
finances publiques. Ça reflète
une maturité sociale qu'on a au
Québec. C'est un budget qui
investit dans la population
active qui va faire en sorte que
la formation soit bien arrimée
au marché du travail. C'est un
budget qui va insister les
travailleurs d'expérience restée
sur le marché du travail.
- Si le gouvernement veut
assurer la croissance des
emplois dans le secteur
manufacturier, il va falloir
aller dans une état plus loin et
investir davantage.
- Comment?
- La question de la main-
d'oeuvre. Il y a 18 000 emplois
vacants dans le secteur
manufacturier. On parle de
crédit pour les travailleurs
expérimentés pour les PME. Il
faudrait élargir cette mesure
aux grandes entreprises.
- Un bon budget qui répond à
plusieurs des demandes que
plusieurs employeurs ont faites.
Un budget qui continue de viser
l'équilibre budgétaire, de
réduire le poids de la dette.
C'est assez prudente dans les
perspectives économiques, les
prévisions économiques.
- Les entreprises vont se
reconnaître dans ce budget à
saveur économique. On va régler
en partie des enjeux de main-
d'oeuvre avec les travailleurs
expérimentés. On aime l'effort
sur un climat d'affaires qui va
aider les entrepreneurs. Pensons
à la réglementation, simplifier
les processus. On veut quand
région les entreprises puissent
mieux se développer. C'est très
positif de notre part.
- Très bon budget pour
l'économie québécoise. Approche
équilibrée entre remettre de
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables, une saine gestion
des finances publiques. Je pense
qu'en ce sens, ça va être très
bien accueilli par les PME.
- C'est une note de A plus,
même!
Les syndicats, est-ce qu'on est
aussi content?
- Le discours est différent. On
réinvestit surtout dans le
béton, dans les écoles, pour
l'arrivée des maternelles quatre
ans. C'est une chose. Ça prend
beaucoup d'argent. Et on
réinvestit pas nécessairement
dans les conditions de travail
des employés du réseau public.
On réinvestit moins dans la
fonction publique dans le réseau
de l'éducation et de la santé ce
qui soulève certaines questions
des fonctionnaires.
- C'est décevant. C'est un
budget de béton pour combler un
peu les fixations du premier
ministre et ça va soulager à peu
près pas les travailleurs des
grands réseaux qui ont été
affectés ces dernières années
par les mesures d'austérité.
Quand tu regardes façon macro,
il y a une croissance des
dépenses en santé de 5,4, il y
en a une en éducation. C'est
assuré pour les prochaines
années. Quand on regarde quoi
les projets, on construit des
maternelles quatre ans, on
construit des places en CHSLD
pour 900 lits de plus, des
maisons d'aînés qui vont
répondre aux besoins de 4000
personnes. Mais pour le
personnel, rien de significatif.
- Ils vantent beaucoup les
fonctionnaires en disant que
c'est des gens compétents. C'est
bien. Par contre, on demeure des
parents pauvres de la fonction
publique. Nous, c'est la moitié
seulement de ce qu'on augmente
en santé.
- Vous, les fonctionnaires?
- Oui.
- On voulait des
réinvestissements massifs en
éducation et en santé. On est
au-delà de l'augmentation des
coûts du système. En éducation,
c'est surtout infrastructure,
nivellement de la taxe scolaire,
les maternelles quatre ans qui
prennent une grande part du
budget. On a droit autant en
santé et en éducation à une
macédoine de petites mesures.
- Disons B pour le monde
syndical. Pour les aînés, on a
l'impression que la ministre a
été efficace.
- C'est la première fois que je
pense un extrait unique des gens
qui représentent les înés.
C'est un peu Noël au mois de
mars pour. Il ne s'attendait pas
à avoir autant de mesures pour
les soins à domicile, les
travailleurs expérimentés pour
les ramener sur le marché du
travail, les places en CHSLD,
l'investissement dans les
maisons des aînés.
C'est la surprise de ce budget.
- On se réjouit de la
collaboration qu'on a faite avec
le gouvernement caquiste qui a
donné des fruits. Pour une fois,
les aînés sont considérés dans
un budget. On a 2,1 milliard
investi pour cinq ans. Le
gouvernement caquiste a envoyé
un message : c'est important de
soutenir les aînés et la qualité
de vie de ces gens. On ne peut
que se réjouir. Il n'y a rien de
parfait. Mais dans les grandes
lignes qu'on avait, on parlait
des soins à domicile, les
travailleurs d'expérience, nous,
en quelque sorte, on se réjouit
de ce qu'on a vu ce matin.
- C'est vraiment de la musique
aux oreilles du gouvernement le
goût d'entendre cette réaction.
Et de Marguerite Blais qui a
bataillé fort. On imagine les
saints qui ont eu lieu dans le
bureau de monsieur Girard.
Merci. Gérald, vous avez
rencontré le ministre plus tôt.
- Vous l'avez vu sourire, le
ministre, au début de son
budget, un sourire franc. Un
homme très heureux de présenter
ce budget. Il était très fier.
Il est très candide aussi. On
pose des questions et il donne
des réponses. C'est assez
agréable à interviewer. Je lui
ai demandé : vous vous dégagez
des marges de manoeuvre pour
baisser les impôts?
- Quand on aura atteint sa cible
ambitieuse, ce sera le temps de
faire une réduction du fardeau
fiscal.
- Juste avant la prochaine
élection? Une bonne vieille
recette électorale?
- Ou après la prochaine
élection.
- D'ailleurs, c'est une vieille
loi de ne pas le faire, promet
de le faire puis après, on le
fait. Vous avez parlé du
programme vert.
- Réno vert.
- C'est terminé dans ce budget.
Est un encadré qui explique
qu'on a plusieurs programmes
complémentaires. On a plusieurs
programmes dédiés à la
rénovation. L'ancien
gouvernement avait prévu qu'il
se termine le programme et nous
conservons ce terme. La
rénovation va très bien au
Québec. C'est pas nécessaire
d'avoir ça.
- Alors, c'est important de dire
que ça fait parti, réno vert,
des programmes d'environnement,
rouler vert va se terminer en
2021. Quand on parle des sommes
aujourd'hui en environnement,
une grosse partie de ces sommes,
c'est le programme rouler vert
qui vous permet une subvention
pour rouler en véhicule
électrique.
- Ça commence à être des
montants, ça va faire 13 000 $
au Québec. Ça commence à être
intéressant pour les gens qui
veulent faire ce virage vers les
voitures électriques. Merci. Luc
Godbout, de l'université de
Sherbrooke. Bonsoir.
Alors, appréciation générale,
comment vous avez perçu ce
premier budget de la CAQ?
- Dans l'ensemble, ils mettent
en oeuvre les promesses qu'ils
avaient annoncées durant la
campagne électorale. C'est
plutôt bien. On est surtout
beaucoup plus ciblé pour ce
premier budget qu'on ne l'était
la dernière année où il y avait
une panoplie d'initiatives. On a
diminué au moins par trois le
nombre de pages. Il y a trois
fois moins de pages aujourd'hui
qu'il y en avait dans le même
exercice il y a un an à peine.
- Moins de fla fla. Des fois,
dans un budget il y a de
l'enflure verbale et on ajoute
plein de petites mesures. On est
allé à l'essentiel, santé,
éducation, les aînés.
- Et aussi dans les mesures
fiscales, vouloir jouer à
l'incitation au travail des gens
de 60 ans et plus. L'initiative
ciblée du côté et des
travailleurs et des PME qui
embauchent ce type de personne.
- Parlez-moi de cette mesure
fiscale. Celle-là, elle semble
important. Ce que ça va changer
quelque chose?
- Ce qu'on observe quand on
regarde le marché du travail
québécois, pour toutes les
catégories d'âge, de 20 à 59
ans, les taux d'emploi sont
toujours meilleurs au Québec en
Ontario. Mais quand on arrive
dans les 60 à 64 ans, 65 à 69
ans, étonnant poisson plus
faible pour toutes sortes de
raisons historiques.
- Les gens prennent le retraite
plutôt au Québec.
- La liberté 55. Ça existait
peut-être parce qu'on a des
régimes de retraite. Les
retraites sont plus tôt ici. Le
ministre avait joué, dans le
passé, un crédit d'impôt pour
travailleurs d'expérience.
Maintenant ça s'appelle crédit
d'impôt pour la prolongation de
carrière. Dès qu'on a 60 ans,
c'est possible d'effacer de
l'impôt sur un 10 000 $ au taux
le plus bas du barème. Ça peut
inciter les gens rester sur le
marché du travail. Et on se
tourne aussi du côté des
entreprises...
- pour des gens qui disent par
exemple : c'est pas tellement
plus payant resté au travail que
d'aller à la retraite, ça va
devenir plus payant travaillé,
vous dîtes?
- Pour les gens de 60 ans,
l'année passée, et n'était pas
admissible à cette mesure.
Maintenant ils seront
admissibles pour une économie de
1500 $. Si on parle de gens à
faible revenu, budget fédéral de
mardi dernier a mis en place des
changements dans le supplément
de revenu garanti. Les deux
budgets vient de donner un coup
de pouce aux travailleurs
faiblement rémunérés s'ils
veulent rester sur le marché du
travail que ça soit plus
attrayant, que ce n'était dans
le passé.
- C'est un gros, moyen coup?
Incitatif majeur, ça va aider un
peu? Comment on peut évaluer
l'impact d'une mesure comme
celle-là?
- Pour les 65 ans et plus, pas
de bonification. La mesure est
telle qu'elle est à part le
changement fédéral du budget de
mardi. Pour les autres, on
bonifie l'aide. Ça devient plus
significatif. Mais ce qu'on
vient faire aussi, on se tombe
du côté des PME et on leur dit :
il y a peut-être des coups à
embaucher des employés
d'expérience. On donne crédit
d'impôt aux PME remboursables
qui peut effacer une grande
partie des cotisations que les
employeurs doivent payer
lorsqu'ils embauchent des
travailleurs, les cotisations au
régime des rentes du Québec.
- C'est un incitatif employé des
gens plus âgés ça veulent leur
coûter moins cher.
- Ça, c'est nouveau.
Pour le moment, on a ciblé les
PME. Peut-être qu'on ouvrira
l'ensemble des entreprises.
- On a vu le ministre Girard
avec ses souliers de course qui
voulait rattraper l'écart de la
richesse entre le Québec et
l'Ontario, le salaire moyen.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce
budget qui va aider le Québec à
rattraper l'Ontario?
- Le ministre, il avait des
souliers de course. C'est pas un
sprint qu'il doit faire, c'est
un marathon. Ces mesures, il
avait déjà commencé dans la mise
à jour économique notamment en
favorisant l'investissement des
entreprises dans du nouveau
matériel, des entreprises
lorsqu'elles investissent dans
des nouveaux équipements, elle
puisse l'amortir plus
rapidement. C'est le fer de
lance. Si les entreprises ont du
meilleur équipement, est-ce que
les employés vont pouvoir
travailler et s'accroître? Dans
le budget aujourd'hui, il y a
pas des tonnes de mesures pour
améliorer la productivité des
entreprises. C'est plus ce qui a
été fait dans la mise à jour
économique. Ici, c'est plus pour
l'emploi des travailleurs
d'expérience.
- À quand les baisses d'impôts?
Comment vous voyez la trame à
partir de maintenant?
- La CAQ a promis
essentiellement pour les
individus trois choses :
réduction des taxes scolaires,
abolition de contribution
additionnelle pour les frais de
garde et bonification des
allocations familiales. L'État
scolaire, c'est fait. Bien qu'on
va annoncer dans les prochaines
années de quelle manière ce sera
réduit. En premier qu'à terme on
aura réduit sur quatre ans. Pour
la contribution additionnelle de
frais de garde, on a annoncé
aujourd'hui que dès cette année,
toutes les familles qui gagnent
en bas de 60 000 $ ne paieront
plus la contribution de frais de
garde. D'ici 2022, ce sera
l'ensemble des ménages à revenus
plus élevés. Pour la location
familles, le montant a été
majoré dans la mise à jour
économique de décembre. On a
ajouté 500 $ pour le deuxième et
troisième enfant. À ce jour, on
n'a pas le plan pour ce qu'ils
vont faire pour respecter la
promesse pour les quatre
prochaines années. La promesse,
c'était de rendre l'aide pour le
deuxième et troisième enfant
aussi généreuse que pour le
premier. Pour le moment, il n'y
a pas de plan de match. Ils
n'ont pas dit nulle part qu'il
ne voulait pas le faire. Ils
vont probablement l'annoncer
l'année prochaine ou l'année
suivante. Pour le moment, on n'a
pas la séquence des baisses
d'impôts pour les allocations
amis. Pour les aînés, il n'y a
rien de nouveau.
- On a vu la réaction pour les
soins à domicile et dans le
secteur de la santé. On semble
satisfait.
- Je vous parle de fiscalité. Il
y a beaucoup plus de choses que
la fiscalité. Il y a un
programme. On rajoute 1,5
milliards dans le service à
domicile. 1,1 milliard dans le
personnel soignant, plus d'un
demi-million dans la maison aux
aînés. Ces descentes qui vont
profiter aux aînés. Sur le plan
fiscal, peu de changement pour
les années dans ce budget. Bien
qu'on ouvre des changements dans
le futur.
- Luc Godbout, directeur du
département de fiscalité de
l'université de Sherbrooke. Il y
en a de moins en moins de
mesures fiscales dans le budget.
Autrefois, il y en avait
davantage et que ces d'autres
gens de mesures, des programmes,
des révolutions fiscales, il n'y
en a pas tant que ça? Vous en
souciez une.
- Je souhaitais une réforme de
la fiscalité et qu'on fasse le
ménage. Le danger avec les
mesures fiscales, elle se
superpose. Il y en a près de 300
au Québec seulement. Est-ce
qu'il y a des mesures qui
profitent à moins de 100
contribuables. Et d'avoir moins
de mesures fiscales, mais des
mesures fiscales plus efficaces
et plus performantes et plus
généreuses.
- Le Godbout, merci beaucoup.
René Vézina, Michel C Auger,
rebonsoir!
Il a pas tiré toutes ces
munitions, ministre.
- Ça va être graduel et
progressiste. C'est déjà
annoncé, comme pour
l'élimination complète des
contributions additionnelles aux
frais de garderie, c'est en
marche. C'est déjà ça. C'est
pour ça qu'on va pouvoir dire...
on sera pas que l'ensemble des
engagements sont repris, mais
que l'essentiel s'y trouve. Je
reviens sur deux éléments
intéressants. On parlait en
début d'émission de l'arrimage
possible entre les mesures du
gouvernement fédéral est celle-
ci. Dans le cas des voitures
électriques, c'est le cas. Donc,
pour ce qui est du Québec, on
est après de 13 000 $ comme
allocations. C'est considérable.
Pour l'accès Internet haute
vitesse, on veut lancer tous les
projets d'ici 2020... ça, c'est
une demande des municipalités,
surtout les municipalités en
région rurale. Au fédéral, ces
2030. J'imagine qu'on va se
parler pour accélérer. C'est un
élément intéressant parce qu'il
y avait une fracture potentielle
est risqué. Je reviens sur un
élément d'actualité. On a ici
glissé rapidement : 1 milliard
de dollars dans une enveloppe
pour accompagner, pour soutenir
des entreprises stratégiques qui
pourraient faire l'objet un jour
de se faire courtiser et
acheter. On pense inévitablement
à SNC-Lavalin. C'est pas mal
d'argent. Je pense qu'on veut se
prémunir du genre de crise comme
on a vécu où les gens
déchiraient leur chemise parce
qu'un fleuron s'en allait. C'est
une somme intéressant qui
pourrait permettre d'agir en
temps et lieu.
- Un autre coussin. Il y a
beaucoup de coussins. Il y avait
tellement de surplus consacré
des coussins pour des imprévus
de ce type. Racheter rapidement
des actions de SNC-Lavalin si
les Chinois voulaient l'acheter.
- Ça va compliquer ses relations
avec le gouvernement fédéral. Il
n'y a pas un gouvernement au
Canada qui peut se permettre de
telles dépenses. Imaginez à
partir de maintenant, on n'a pas
assez d'argent pour Québec. Vous
aviez l'argent et vous avez fait
d'autres chats. On est en
élection en Alberta. Un des
thèmes, ce sera la péréquation.
Imaginez avec des surplus comme
ça, même si c'est pas tout à
fait juste de mêler la
péréquation à ça, combien le
débat sur la péréquation va
devenir compliqué à partir de
maintenant.
- En conclusion, l'accueil est
bon. On l'a vu. Les aînés, c'est
évident, les milieux d'affaires,
ils sont très contents. Les
syndicats ont des réserves, mais
quand même, on ne déchire pas
notre chemise. Politiquement,
c'est un test réussi pour le
ministre Gérard?
- Avec les surplus qu'il avait,
il ne pouvait pas se tromper.
René, conclusion?
- Comme premier budget, c'est un
exercice réussi. Il faudra voir
dans les détails. Il faudra voir
les mesures ciblées un peu
partout. Je pense que il y a eu
des notes. Je pense que dans
l'ensemble, on pourra voir, mais
comme je disais, quand on nage
dans l'abondance, on est capable
de s'entourer de bons gilets de
sauvetage, c'est difficile de
caler.
- On se retrouve à 17 heures.
Gérald, mission...
il a pas fini son discours. Il
est en train de parler. Là tu
parlais beaucoup de gens des
milieux d'affaires.
Les municipalités, on verra ce
qu'on dira de ce côté. Sinon,
plutôt bien reçu.
- Absolument. Les milieux
d'affaires auraient mis la
baisse d'impôts tout de suite.
Il a plutôt joué de prudence sur
la baisse d'impôts. C'est assez
sage. Il avait une possibilité
d'aller de l'avant avec une
baisse d'impôts immédiatement.
Il se dit, contenu du message
envoyé à la CAQ, il se dit :
j'ai investi dans des missions
fondamentales, les aînés,
l'éducation, la santé, les
infrastructures, il faut que je
m'occupe du manque de main-
d'oeuvre, du vieillissement de a
population, ralentissement de
l'économie qui est en cours. On
sent que le ministre a voulu
jouer de prudence avec ce
premier budget aujourd'hui.
- On se retrouve aux 17 heurts.
Merci beaucoup de toutes ces
explications toujours claires.ÀA
tout de suite! Va se retrouver
donc de l'autre côté avec toute
l'actualité. Il y a ça et
d'autres choses parce que ça
avance pas mal aujourd'hui à
Ottawa. Vous avez vu peut-être
Jane Philpott qui a retiré une
torpille en direction de son
chef Justin Trudeau. Ce n'est
pas terminé cette histoire de
SNC-Lavalin à Ottawa. D'autres
nouvelles également que l'on
suit. À tout de suite. Merci. Au
revoir.
- Des travailleurs qui ne
demandent pas mieux que de
continuer à travailler.
J'annonce une bonification du
crédit d'impôt pour travailleurs
d'expérience et un abaissement à
60 ans à l'âge d'admissibilité
de ce crédit d'impôt qui
s'appellera crédit d'impôt pour
la prolongation de carrière afin
de mieux refléter l'objectif de
cette mesure fiscale. Près de
158 000 travailleurs pourront
profiter de cette mesure.
J'annonce également une
réduction des charges sur la
masse salariale. Cette réduction
profitera à 34 000 PME de tous
secteurs d'activité.
(applaudissements)
Bonsoir. Voici ce qui marque
l'actualité maintenant.
Éric Girard présent un budget
équilibré sans baisse d'impôts
avec des augmentations de
dépenses de plus de 5 %